to the list of what's been destroyed in
ukraine we can now add this pre-school
in the second largest city of kharkiv
the high school next door also struck
every day this war is shattering more
and more civilian lives
the message from ukraine's president is
that he's going nowhere filming himself
in his office for the first time since
the invasion began
i stay here in kiev at bankover street i
don't hide and i'm not afraid of anyone
i will stay here as long as it's
necessary to win our patriotic war
nashi which is nyani vini
and across his country the sounds of war
rumble on here in the coastal city of
mikolaim every promise of a cease-fire
and the precious chance for people to
reach safety has been broken so far
i have tears running down my face
although i'm a retired soldier
my wife was injured by shrapnel
yesterday she's now at hospital number
four
she was just about saved there
now she's there and i'm here trying to
sort things out somehow
there's little optimism today's
ceasefire will be any more successful
ukrainian cities are under siege
under relentless russian shelling
hospitals are running out of supplies
food is adrenaline
and civilian calgaries are mounting
with no let up in the death and
destruction in ukraine what of the
economic punishment for russia the u.s
perhaps about to do what europe says it
can't and stop importing russian oil
whatever the cost to the markets and
consumers
it can mean little to the youngest
victims of this crisis this boy crossing
the border into poland safe yes but how
can we ever measure the damage that's
already been done to so many others greg
milam sky news washington